is actually quite amazing there is zero
evidence
that depression is a chemical imbalance
in the brain involving serotonin
despite years of selling
massive amount of drugs the amount of
money that these drug companies made on
this theory is astronomical it's only a
theory and there's no evidence that
increasing or decreasing serotonin in
the brain does anything for depression
it has been found that ssris selected
serotonin reuptake Inhibitors based
these are medications to block the
re-uptake or the absorption of Serotonin
so you'll have more serotonin in the
brain they have found that when you give
someone this drug it does increase at
least temporarily the available
serotonin in the brain the drug trials
on ssris showed that these
antidepressants are barely
indistinguishable from the actual drug
and the placebo in treating depression
but they come with a package a lot of
side effects including something called
a black box warning in fact all
psychiatric drugs have a black box
warning which means they have a high
risk of suicide thoughts and behaviors
but on top of that there's some serious
side effects involving the sex organs
talking about
lack of orgasm
penile and genital anesthesia which is
the loss of feeling of your private
parts erectile dysfunction premature
ejaculation so it's just bizarre to me
that we have all these high risk for
side effects yet we don't have any
evidence on this theory that it actually
will work for you there's even some
research that shows that it's the
elevation it's the high levels of
Serotonin that causes depression not low
levels and in other experiments where
they actually tried to lower serotonin
they did not find that a person gets
depressed when you lower their serotonin
so as far as the treatment of depression
with Pharmaceuticals
you really need to think twice and three
times and four times and evaluate all
the risks and the benefits as well as
understanding the mechanism of what
happens when you're taking a uh a drug
to manipulate the neurotransmitter so
neurotransmitters are communication
particles and they go from one neuron to
the next very similar to hormones that
work in your blood yet neurotransmitters
work within the nervous system and
there's quite a few neurotransmitters I
think there's over a hundred and they
create all sorts of effects but when you
artificially try to manipulate these
neurotransmitters
you kind of screw up the whole
communication within the neurons itself
and when we talk about depression does
depression cause
body problems
okay or is it body problems causing
depression is the chicken or the egg
well I think it's both because you can
have a stress event you can have a
severe loss and be depressed and have
that depression severely affect your
physical
Health but on the other hand you could
have certain types of physical health
problems and deficiencies that can
directly cause depression and that is
the area that I want to talk about so
there are four main things that I think
cause a physical reason why a person is
depressed the first one is insomnia okay
insomnia increases the risk of getting
depression by a factor of 10 x that's a
thousand percent increase
okay that's pretty significant and when
someone can't sleep they usually have a
problem with this neurotransmitter
called acetylcholine okay
acetylcholine is the neurotransmitter
that the vagus nerve operates with
and the Vex nerve is all about uh
countering stress as far as it being the
parasympathetic nervous system opposing
the sympathetic which is a flutterified
the parasympathetic is all about rest
and digest and this is why if you're
deficient in acetylcholine
boy you have problems with digestion you
can't make hydrochloric acid you can't
release bile you can't release enzymes
your peristalsis the ability of your
stool to go through the tubes through
the digestive tract are inhibited so
acetylcholine is very very important in
digestion but also equally important in
rest so there are several things that
can help increase acetylcholine as a
neurotransmitter
having enough vitamin B1 very important
having enough choline on my DNA test one
of the problems I had genetically is I
have a difficult time absorbing choline
so I have to take more choline and the
foods that are highest in choline are
number one egg yolks okay egg yolks are
very high in choline beef liver which a
lot of people don't like so I'd
recommend doing egg yolks and fatty fish
another vitamin that can greatly help
increase your acetylcholine is vitamin D
okay I would take
at least 10 000 I use
before bed it helps a lot of people with
insomnia and you might even need to take
a little bit more because so many people
are deficient in vitamin D and also
getting out and having enough sun is
also uh even a better choice if you have
the option but just don't let yourself
get burned but with the sun you not just
get vitamin D you also get melatonin
okay which it comes from the infrared
over 50 of the sun's rays are infrared
and it penetrates even to your clothes
even through a hat so you can get the
benefit of the Melatonin increase as
well through the Sun but vitamin D is
very very important vitamin B5 is also
very important vitamin B5 is very easy
to get from pretty much almost all food
so that's usually not the problem and
then another thing that can also help
increase acetylcholine is magnesium and
the type of magnesium that I would
recommend
for insomnia would be magnesium
threonate that's the one that penetrates
the blood-brain barrier and can greatly
help that neurotransmitter and help you
sleep how does someone end up with lower
amounts of acetylcholine one big one is
high carb diets sugar insulin resistance
okay that blocks these neurotransmitters
especially acetylcholine all right so
number one is insomnia number two is the
thing that you get as a side effect from
insomnia chronic fatigue right you're
going to be tired if you have insomnia
so chronic fatigue can definitely cause
someone to be depressed because they
don't have the energy and it could be a
dysfunctional mitochondria okay the
energy Factory because the person's
missing something like
coenzyme Q10 or even B1 also a person
could be chronically fatigued if they
have a virus okay I'm talking about one
of those viruses that can go in
remission and out of remission like the
Epstein-Barr virus which a lot of people
have a problem with
and then they can become chronically
fatigued and then they can become
depressed and you just have to find out
why you're chronically fatigued is it
your diet is it the lack of sleep is it
a viral infection which actually it's
very common to have a viral component
because of the next thing number three
stress especially chronic stress can
reactivate a virus and cause chronic
fatigue syndrome and fibromyalgia and so
chronic stress is another huge factor of
why people can become depressed that
chronic stimulation of cortisol which
directly will cause insomnia a lot of
people who have these viruses that are
coming out in remission it's usually
always after some stress event so
this is not a little thing it's a big
thing so if you are chronically stressed
find out whatever stressing about and
see what you can do to improve it and
number four nutritional deficiencies can
directly cause depression the big one is
a vitamin D deficiency now do you see
how they cross over from not having
enough sun or enough vitamin D or even
the stress factor can deplete you of
vitamin D but a vitamin D deficiency can
directly make you depressed I mean think
about what happens during the winter
months so many people get the blues it's
a vitamin D minimally 10 000 IUS but I
would usually if someone is depressed
recommend like twenty thousand to thirty
thousand I use every single day and uh
if it's going to work it's going to work
within a few days and you'll feel much
better the next efficiency that can
cause direct depression would be a B12
deficiency this can usually come from a
person being on at acids or they have
inflammatory problems in the gut
or they're a vegan and don't consume
animal products or they had gastric
bypass or they're getting older and they
just don't have enough hydrochloric acid
in their stomach so there's many
different reasons a vitamin B1
deficiency which usually comes from
consuming too much sugar coffee tea
chocolate
um mainly though too many carbs can
cause depression but most of the time it
starts off with
anxiety and worry and then that can lead
to depression so anxiety is a lot of
worry and stress
depression is kind of like I give up I'm
hopeless or I'm sad if someone has a
magnesium deficiency they can also be
chronically fatigued or they can be
depressed because the influence of
magnesium on the energy generation of
ATP they can just have not enough energy
and they're going to feel very very down
and sometimes depressed or exhausted I
mean when you think about it can you
actually be depressed if you have a lot
of energy
it's kind of hard and the last point
about depression as far as a nutritional
efficiency is the omega-3 DHA because
that makes up a good portion of your
brain and if you're deficient in that
because you don't consume DHA that can
create depression so those are the four
factors I do want to add one more thing
okay it's exercise and the lack of it
the more you exercise the less depressed
you're going to be you're going to build
up your mitochondria you're going to
generate energy it's going to help you
reduce stress it's going to help you
sleep better so don't forget about
exercise now there's a bit more
information on insomnia that I want you
to know about from this video right here
check it out